increasingly you will find me armed
because there are
gangs prowling the streets of america
that are committing violence all over
the place looting
burning tearing down statues killing
people it's dangerous out there these
days
and so it's no surprise that more and
more americans are arming themselves
to protect their own lives and their
loved ones and their property but i
guess you're not allowed to do that
anymore
not in america you're actually supposed
to just let violent gangs
run roughshod over your property and
threaten your life that's what the
mainstream media has been telling us
joining us now to discuss not just the
broad topic
but what happened to him personally is
that lawyer from st
louis that we saw standing with his wife
outside of their home
with their firearms protecting their
lives and property
mark mccloskey personal injury attorney
in st louis
who had the audacity the gall to defend
his home mr mccloskey thank you so much
for being here
thank you for having me on the show so
mr mccloskey we all saw what happened
the first time
this uh gang of very very peaceful
protesters we are told
uh breaks break some of your property
comes on threatens you
uh they go on by you defend yourself
the update since then is that the
the protesters the rioters came back
that's true we had gotten a tip from
from somewhere that i can't disclose
that not only were they coming back but
they were coming back specifically to
quote
get us unquote and to burn down the
house
and and it was even advertised
on the website for the entity that was
operating this uh this protest
something called expect us that they
were going to do a return to our house
last friday night
and this is not just some idle threat
because we've seen that these rioters
have been
burning down many buildings all around
the country and harming people and
killing people and doing all sorts of
terrible things
so you had to take this threat seriously
and yet in this bizarro world that we're
living in
you have been excoriated by the
mainstream institutions
by politicians by the media simply for
defending yourself
that's true and you know i want to set
the record straight on one thing i've
been reading a lot of reports about me
on the media
some of whom have accused me of being a
democrat and i have donated money to
various candidates
particularly ones that were personal
friends of mine over the year but i've
been a lifelong republican
another thing i'd like to clear up is
that the media reports me as being a
supporter of the black lives matter
movement and i am certainly not black
lives matter to my
understanding is a marxist organization
opposed to everything i stand for and
everything i hold near and dear
i do stand for equal justice for all
under the law
but that's got nothing to do with this
terrorist organization known as black
lives matter
absolutely right and i'm actually
somewhat surprised to hear you say that
i i should have learned my lesson by now
but i believed the media when they said
that you were a democrat
and when they said that you supported
blm but there's this
there's this issue in the country right
now which is black lives matter has
nothing to do with black lives mattering
you know the black lives matter
organization the leaders
have described themselves as marxists
explicitly
they've called for the destruction of
the nuclear family they've called for
overturning the whole system so that's
very different so i i don't know what's
worse
mark to be smeared as a bigot or to be
smeared as a democrat
frankly these days maybe there might not
be such a difference
well you know if you don't like what
somebody says today all you have to do
is say they're a racist
that's right that's right what what sort
of uh
pushback have you got and obviously we
know what the mainstream press has given
to you
has there been any reaction in your own
community or from
from local officials as well to punish
you for having the goal to defend
yourself
well let me let me paint the picture a
little bit about what happened last
friday
by thursday afternoon we had started to
when we got the tip and we realized this
was a very credible threat
we started trying to hire private
security local secondary
duty officers weren't interested in
doing it we
got in touch with some special forces
type
contractors who provide security all
over the planet that they didn't want
the bad press
finally finally by thursday afternoon at
about three o'clock
uh we had been told by the last group
these were some special forces guys
just walk away from your house abandon
it and i said i'm just not going to do
that
and my wife was just beside herself so
without dropping any names i called up
a another fox host um who put the word
out
my lawyer got finally got a hold of a
entity out of texas
it brought up some serious firepower
local secondary employment police from
outside the san andreas area
made themselves available by friday
night we had
cooperation from the top of the
government on down
the local police encouraged that we were
supporting them as well
stood up like champs i had chief john
hayden in front of the house for most of
the night
and for an example of how policing can
actually work effectively
the chief got together and he had his
lieutenant who is in charge of
civil disobedience or whatever the
euphemism they use these days
came out met with my private security
guys told him
how they thought it would work best to
have a show of force but not of weapons
our guys did exactly what the chief
wanted the chief
stayed there and mediated the entire
thing the crowd was loud
um they were angry but they weren't
permitted to do anything
destructive or violent and they moved on
well i guess this is the the
main issue here because i was so shocked
when when people attacked you and your
wife
and even some moderates and
conservatives did
and they said you don't have a right to
defend yourself at the same time that
they're calling to
defund the police so if you if you don't
have the police and you're not allowed
to defend yourself
then i guess the only alternative is to
as you
say let the mob come and burn your house
down as they've done
in many other places and here in saint
louis i mean the last
riot uh we're not allowed to use that
word peaceful protest rights peace
before this one on june the second they
burn downtown
as i said before i watched on live
television a 7-eleven downtown bricks
through the window people looting it
then setting the fire then the fire
totally engulfing the business i'm
watching this
live from a helicopter feed for 40
minutes and no one ever shows up no
police no fire no nothing
i look over at my wife and i say we're
here all alone if this happens to us
you know we're we're all alone we can't
depend on anybody else
that first night that june 28th that's
exactly the way it was
this group came up the street uh
screaming and chanting
and they come up parallel to our gate
and we look around there's no security
our private security our neighborhood's
got you know a couple of private guards
they're not present no saint louis city
police present and then the gates burst
open they come right at us
i mean it was it was a pretty pretty uh
pardon that expression stinking
frightening of course it would be i mean
how could it not be and i think one
thing that's been a little unclear in
all of this
is the meteor trying to play down the
the effect of the protesters on
on your property they're saying oh no
they were keeping off the property they
weren't damaging any property at all
this was a huge overreaction they did
damage property is that correct
they did and you know despite the fact
that i took
pictures of that gate i looked at the
metadata on my on my cell phone
i took the pictures of the broken gate
at 7 42 p.m that night
as recently as i can't remember given
i've been up for a long time but
in one of the interviews uh i think it
was on breakfast britain
the uh the commentator says well we
don't know when those pictures were
taken do we on the pretense
that the pictures were faked or
something and i said yes i do i took
them myself and they were taken five
minutes after the crowd moved on
of course and what do you think the
effect of this is
on the election and what do you think
the election how do you think the
election is affecting
all of this because it seems to me that
there is a political overtone to
everything
here i can't tell which side it would
possibly be helping
but it does seem to me even though every
year we hear this the most important
election in our lifetimes and it's the
most important election in our lifetimes
when they're when one side of this
country
is actually encouraging rioters and
roving mobs
to go attack people break their property
and threaten their lives when the
when the country is actually burning
down that that might make it the most
important election of our lifetimes
well let me say this i heard the
president's speech at mount rushmore
where he talks about
fighting against leftist extremists and
marxists
and then the mainstream media says he's
being
divisive i'm 63 years old but i never
thought i would live long enough to hear
the media in this country say
that fighting against communism is
divisive yeah
that we should live in harmony with the
communists within our own country
and just let them do what they want
right that was such a shock to me
i think the answer to your question is i
think there are elements
in our country probably represented by
most of the mainstream media
that wants this to accelerate to a point
where there has to be a confrontation
not between civil authorities but
between individuals
and the mob have a kent state type
situation and then blame it all on trump
yeah uh right i i think there's we know
that this is
this is organized at a pretty
sophisticated level
we know that this is being pushed by
serious institutions of power and so it
would seem to me that there is a
political strategy
here as well but i want to get back to
something you said earlier which is
there's this
truly defamatory line out there that
you're a lifelong democrat
and you said no i'm a i'm a lifelong
republican but i've given a little money
if you know friends of mine are running
for office as democrats and this reminds
me of a of a period in america that i
think
might be gone which is uh you know you
could be a republican
and you could have democratic friends
and maybe if one of them runs for a
local office maybe you give a little
money
to them as well but but it wasn't like
this complete total polarization
where the left says if you don't
disagree with us on everything we're
going to burn your house down
do you think that that period of
american life is over i mean are we
are we sort of just hopelessly polarized
at this point going into the future
you know i i hope not but it's very
discouraging i mean there there would be
people
that i i basically put people running
for office into two categories one are
people that i think
genuinely care for the people and for
the country and will do their job
honorably regardless of what their party
affiliation is
and then there's people that that just
want power and control
and and don't care how they how they
acquire it and when i've when i've
donated to people of both parties
i've tried to limit my money exclusively
to those people who i believe
genuinely have the best interests of our
civilization
our nation and everything that our
forefathers worked for for the last 244
years
at heart and not just our own egos or
the enhancement of power
right are are you and your wife afraid
of the mob
coming back yet again i mean is this
over has this finished you know or or do
you think that you'll continue to be
attacked either by the mob or by
the civil authority you know my we have
not
heard whether or not either either one
of us is going to be indicted yet
although that's still out there but i'm
i'm sitting in my office building which
is three blocks from my house
i'm looking at plywood out the window
and we're still boarded up
the front of the house is still boarded
up and is that a reasonable precaution
or is that
being a little paranoid i don't know but
i know for one thing for sure i don't
want to be burned i don't want to be
killed for this
yep that's right and i think uh i i
think i speak for a lot of people
when i say you you and your wife have
have become an inspiration
i know that the media were raking you
over the coals but
a lot of us are out there who were
looking in that and saying yes
finally somebody is pushing back they're
not going to allow
self-proclaimed marxists to run
roughshod not just over
property and and over innocent lives but
over our country itself i was joking
that i want brooks brothers to make that
image of you with the with the rifle
to be the the cover of their next
catalog i i don't know if they're going
to take me up
on on that opportunity but i i really
appreciate i would not hold my breath
unfortunately it's too bad but i
appreciate you taking the time with us
and for clearing up
the record you know on on your political
views on your
alleged support of black lives matter
which turns out like so much in the
media
to be a lie i appreciate you correcting
the record i'm sure now they're going to
go and lie about you a lot more
so i suppose then we will have to have
you back on to clear up the record again
but from the bottom of my heart i i
thank you for standing up for that
symbol
and i also wish you and your wife the
best of luck moving forward
i sure appreciate it and thanks for the
opportunity my pleasure thank you very
much
mark mark mccloskey you know they they
really stood firm at a time when a lot
of people in this country
are not you know even people who should
know better even people who
understand what marxism is understand
what radicalism is don't want to see
washington statues be pulled down a lot
of people are trying to
stay on the sidelines and uh that's not
a good idea what
what if we learned about appeasement
well you feed the crocodile
hopefully the crocodile eats you last
appeasement does not work folks
one has to pick a side
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software
for contractors and small businesses
spend less time billing and more time
making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description